and action reject Nation assemble that was
basically the same but yeah absolutely yeah
I tried doing it earlier guys reject nation
very good must assemble Terror every morning
were we watching today Tara Transformers rise
of the beasts so Tara is uh my friend who
did not catch this in the theaters and I said
good because the day that I had a screening
to go watch this I had to stay behind and
handle a bunch of editing while Coy and John
went to go watch it let's see so busy oh my
God I'm so busy friends got to see it and
you got left in the duck feel bad for me and
admire my dedication to his career and so
I was like all right I guess I'm reacting
to this movie now so I'm glad you could be
here with me today so you know what to do
ladies and gentlemen leave a like on this
video also subscribe click the notification
Bell I don't know if our next reaction is
up here on this channel follow Tara Erickson
on her YouTube oh yeah
I'll ring the bell and subscribe follow her
please I'm so sorry Tara it's been a very
long day we were shooting this on the Tuesday
we're a billion trailers have come out and
I got a midnight shoot ahead of me feel sorry
for me and admire my dedication to my crafts
reaction not so long or he's sticking with
your own copy of Transformers rise of the
Beast of course available for a super sexy
rejects over at our patreon page we cover
so many exclusive things over there with reactional
Heights and watch songs included this intro
is done it's done let's watch this movie
[Music] oh
I've always loved the sound design
Hasbro oh they make toys yes yes welcome to
my brain I made that they make GI Joe oh yeah
yeah there's a legend that precedes the dawn
of our civilization so powerful that it consumed
entire planets as fuel ah if you believe such
a thing could be true until the day we saw
Unicron with our own eyes that voiceover is
so freaking great
Unicron he wanted our greatest technology
the transwarf key and he sent his most powerful
henchman Scourge Scourge you son of a [__]
oh awesome okay I'm excited oh my God this
is great it's like a king kong Transformer
Primo whoa
air razor get us down now your time to leave
them a primal it's that Terror and I greet
each other [Laughter] [Music]
oh he's gonna all right buddy damn this is
gonna be a fight you won't forget
taking this
savory damn
[Music]
oh oh no the whoa that quick whoa whoa benefits
Mighty Unicron oh my sacrifice will be our
oath to preserve the key no matter the cost
that's a cool shot
I alone Will Rain Supreme wow [Music] wow
holy junk this is real pretty and mesmerizing
damn that's cool okay rise of the beasts I'm
into it
[Music] government agencies worried about
us Tails us Sonic and Tails are there nicknames
Power Rangers Hasbro yeah no it's nothing
it's fun Sickle cells must be blocking the
blood flow again he's smart and capable you
find this alone we find it together together
one team on team word home team in it I am
now endeared to him me too put your skills
to work and get you some real money yes I'm
a dude can't even afford cable it's my own
foreign nature of modern day capitalism
that's great
it's cool that they put the Twin Towers back
there oh yeah as a dirty reminder
awesome age of Extinction oh man you guys
know how I love my Dinosaurs the police are
here they busted an art auction but they want
a second opinion would they trust an intern's
opinion
looks like air razor really and he has a there's
like a thing on his chest ah
cool cool I'm gonna get a feature in Minerva
Julia [Music] I mean why is she not allowed
in there when she clearly knows way more than
everybody else she's an intern interns should
be allowed to do stuff I know we're a little
behind on the bill three months behind and
until your account is current you can't bring
your brother here I've told you that he's
11 years old yeah but money's money yeah man
I'm here for an interview with the head of
security Mr Bishop it's been canceled oh that's
too bad your own commanding officer called
me back said you were brave but unreliable
your head was always somewhere else God we
need that character Arc by the end of this
movie I I the breakers and I can't have someone
like you mess up what I built uh what yeah
excuse you sir rude and you don't know anything
about me I know you don't know how to be part
of a team I think by the end of this movie
you will learn how to be a part of a team
he won't be so independent they give a ton
of paper to Charities every year to make themselves
feel better stop and it's about to be easy
as hell so why'd you wait the one going in
there doing it um
I don't think that the statuette is Horus
the boys dated it around 5000 BC right the
Nubians they never even had contact with the
Egyptians until 600 years after that oh interesting
it's not some Egyptian god it's something
else yeah so I guess when the primals came
here they came here like thousands of years
ago I think so and she said Inca and uh what's
the other one Jesus
[Music] great excuse me yes oh oh cool that
was great if that impresses you wait till
the rest of the movie
oh is this gonna be a meat cute I hope so
he runs into her she's smart he's smart ooh
robots in Disguise cool
uh portion it feels very Michael Bay
a little wiggle feel that snagging nice
oh [__] [__]
I had a little anxiety there
is she oh
girl you're gonna have to find some gorilla
glue or you're gonna be fired
it's a beacon okay
oh it's our boy [Music]
that's so cool this cannot be calling all
Autobots calling our Autobots yes
oh hell yes RC what am I looking at Away Home
ah I have Goosebumps this is an emergency
can you hear me Mirage hey you gotta operate
it now you better okay skit skedaddle yeah
of course I'm trying the course
oh [__] see ya
now let's talk to your manifestation
now yo Rick what do we do no I cannot hear
you right oh you dick oh man yeah you did
[Music] [Laughter]
[Music] top tier manifestation to make the
car stop [Applause] [Music] yep saw that coming
oh no oh no
prime time that cop is dead that cop is way
dead or maybe just um differently abled now
oh cool cool awesome
oh yeah
oh it's got nipple chills
hahaha [Laughter]
The Mirage
haha wow this is really well orchestrated
how do they do that that's cool
I haven't cooped up forever dude I can tell
you how
back up well that's with the aggression well
I thought after the car chase we were boys
we gonna hit me
tough guy I like that I like it a lot
the name's Mirage fist bump yeah give me a
little give me a little give me a kill tap
there you go now we're friends word
yes you're so freaking cool
I already like this way more than the Michael
Bay once life so much more it's awesome yes
so we got here [Music] who are you human I'm
nobody I ain't even seen nothing I'm not even
seeing anything right now private Noah Diaz
U.S army multiple commendations a wizard with
electronics I will deal with your mistake
later it was thought to be lost thousands
of years ago it was once used to open space-time
portals yes it was Sir John Rich planets throughout
the Universe yes yes after seven long years
stranded on Earth we finally found a way home
seven long years in the new Museum on Ellis
Island no we can't we can't what we need is
a quiet way in
they have just the guy how about him he could
do it what about for cash you help us get
this key so we can get off this rock then
you get to save your brother I let you sell
me
Ferrari cool I like how Optimus in this one
is standoffish against humans because it's
before all the events of those Michael Bay
ones hers was supposed to be a pit stop a
place for us to regroup and the war back home
Prime feels like it's his fault we've been
stranding here like he has to fix it all on
his own poor Prime has guilt man you need
to switch it up you need to turn into a helicopter
or a speedboat or something I got something
way better than that
I like this Mirage character yeah he's great
at least Mirage is one of us we should not
be relying on a human there my friends I know
one was good to you Bailee Steinfeld you care
I do not want you going to that drive-in theater
anymore
oh Optimus but it's such a joy this is going
to be the Journey of how Optimus learn to
trust humans ah yeah all thanks to this one
gent finally the hunt draws to a close full
shot they must have been looking for thousands
of years oh
are you okay killer Noah it's not what it
looks like it's
oh my God what's going on here don't move
oh no no I like how their solution was just
blast a big hole in there and then go retrieve
it yeah they just looks scene
oh sneaky little spiders guys we got company
let's go come on now
[Music] the way they're shot so cool
[Applause]
cool
yeah yes uh oh no when an inferior being meets
a higher power oh wow good timing there scourge
well this reminds me of Jurassic Park but
with Transformers
oh good shot oh whoa that's spooky
nice
go find your friends I don't think a door
is going to stop him oh it did oh it is oh
okay all right New York's finest doors right
here ooh smart yeah yeah fire extinguisher
blind them thanks
spray it [Music]
damn you guys are good survivors
oh
the key get it
God damn dang it
man
oh oh we got right under the armpit no
no I don't like it uh this is how you can
do Transformers action and you call yourself
a crime is would be ashamed premise good reference
oh my goodness this is like sad to watch I
do not like seeing them little things getting
in my way me
oh no no no no no no no no I don't ah that
makes me sad what that can't be right
oh
no
[Music]
no yes yes
it's her statue it's your statue I love how
the Transformers are like actual characters
and you can because you could tell what's
going on in the actions and you care yeah
my dark master oh scourge's soul is too dark
for it's just too dark this is like what I
wanted the Transformers movies to always be
yeah so I'm like So Satisfied right now the
Galaxy will once again be yours to Feast on
my master I should have known better than
to rely on humans goddamn it's not his fault
Optimus Because of You Unicron will now use
the key to consume every planet in the universe
he doesn't have the key amen at least not
all of it you gotta learn to not keep blaming
not all of it broke the key into two pieces
for safe keeping then splintered and went
into hiding smart I am the last of all kind
it's in Peru how do you know that it's the
symbols on the stone because I'm the smartest
one in the museum if you can track those symbols
to Peru soak in the tarragons we need to get
there before they do the transform key is
our only way home if this dude gets a hold
of that thing this game over devour Earth
I'm going out of the question no offense you're
my home to a guy who couldn't even protect
his ouch that's a sick burn Elena will you
lead us to this Temple she has to stop the
end of the world actually you'll be saving
Two Worlds even like the human characters
uh
we'll be back oh [__] I was literally
wondering like how does is he able to control
his weight distribution on here trying to
stop the end of the world the world's ending
no you know I'm not gonna let that happen
that's why I have to leave I'll go get my
things oh I love how this is adjusting so
well it's Greatest Adventure it's too dangerous
Chris and I need you to stay here and take
care of Mom oh he's got to be the man of the
house now watch out for my brother if he gets
hurt I'm coming after you don't worry I got
Noah's back okay on team home team son
they like messing the [__] out of those
shots like that's insane I'm like seamless
how do they do that the Transformers even
look real in the day yeah
that's freaking cool
oh
[Music] yeah I'm walking to Peru
Stratosphere in a previous Transformers movie
but I'm not sure I don't remember him but
I also don't remember what I had for breakfast
so we gotta destroy it they can't unite the
key without both pieces we gotta think about
us no you gotta learn to work on a team exactly
wheel Jack needs to fix that power steering
I've always taken in a harmonious moment between
a Serene butterfly unruffled caterpillar
so where'd you get that accent what accent
you know what I'm saying I'm just I'm saying
it's cool I want to assume that you speak
Spanish too a little racist her menu so he
just has an accent I guess I thought he was
going to respond in Spanish it's a festival
that shuts down the whole city guess it's
a night Mission then we must retrieve the
other half time is of the essence me and Elena
will do it y'all never make it two blocks
there's human security all around the church
well hiding Plain Sight we'll blend in with
the parade that's racist Noah y'all know it
think fast starters oh and if you need help
just holler he's like a piece of Mirage now
that's awesome the way they necessitate the
humans in this is well done and I like Noah
and Optimus being at odds and haven't overcome
that I'm In Color Me impressed Tara Color
Me impressed
ASA I'm blending in man hablo espanol I'm
not racist
Autobots must be using their new pets to reach
the turkey's gotta be in here somewhere man
they did that so fast yeah
not lined up right oh it's like a video game
oh cool they got a Hasbro it
there's another one
levels I hate it's been way too much time
trying to figure it out nowhere
oh
I feel like there'll be a lot of people like
who would have done that by accident this
moves yeah who moved that other one
you dead yet wait did you just call me Sonic
I think that's a temple
you can call Mirage what's another Sonic character
you call them knuckles I think we found what
we came here for
oh are you even pushing me is your penis this
small
oh it's already gone I found something you
see any symbols two of them
that actually got me hang tight I'm on the
way cool [Music]
people in Peru are freaking out right now
you're tearing up our Pebble streets man
wow do something you want me to do oh yeah
use your yeah oh that was easy you got a gun
this whole time he didn't know that [Applause]
Ah that's so cool what the hell are you doing
I'm going to take that key and then take off
his head nice all right Opti oh wow all right
[Music] shot
[Music]
the f word
[Music] nice shot that's awesome yeah grass
coming out of his mouth yeah hold on no
foreign [Music] holy moly you're going to
die on this Speck of dust I can think of no
better place to bury you ah man Voice work
is so good
holy [__]
oh she'd be raised in hell
uh
uh not this time
oh no no no no no this is tearing up my soul
they do a really good job at establishing
a scourge's real threat a real jerk I just
realized where the plot is going I don't ruin
it though don't ruin it
yes yes stay away from my friends oh Mirage
you boys got this
stranger danger over here kitty kitty stand
down oh come on
this is so awesome oh my gosh just a build
up to them finally encountering each other
and our leader Optimus Prime Optimus Prime
that's like my name he has half of the key
we must find the second piece before he does
where is it now come me I can sense how Optimus
will come around to the humans Optimus must
come around to the humans because they're
helping you little bro's got this thing about
using real names over the airwaves so he gave
me this to keep tabs on you I'm sure I'm keeping
my promise uh great the crown destroyed our
world we took an oath dedicated to the preservation
of life and Earth has been a safe Refuge that's
where Optimus is going to be like really ha
ha
oh interesting so they're like they hang out
with the Maximus this is amaru family of the
last descendants of a tribe that has watched
over us for hundreds of years really and together
we protected its people and oh I have Goosebumps
the maximals have already sacrificed one home
to protect the Universe I won't risk losing
another as a leader I know you understand
Prime is going to learn from his future self
man she's gonna die I don't know this is raw
Energon I've be yeah it would take a great
power to ignite it greater than anything we
have here oh they could find that power I
see that you were surprised we entrust the
key to them I've been amongst them a long
time now there is more to them than Meats
I love it
play on Transformers meets the eyes come on
I get I was with you
fail at this killing my family down yeah just
like him Optimus Optimus stubborn you think
he's some some general barking orders but
all I see is a big brother trying to protect
his family humans are well done thank you
this is really great right I love how they
reflect each other that's so good especially
when you compare it are you okay no she's
not okay and I don't like seeing it she's
becoming corrupted it's like a Venom mine
no
eraser no miss me no Elena get out of here
we have to destroy no no no no no no man but
if you destroy that key our home will be lost
forever don't
it got all worked up
oh gosh she's turned this just got personal
[Music] oh what a cool shot oh no wouldn't
I kill you already no that's a different one
oh I'm the maximal that's going to rip out
your spark we'll see about that kill them
no no you can't kill your family oh
oh he has to kill her
that's so sad
[Music] oh yeah
oh that's really sad I actually teared up
over a Transformer
I was alone I would have been scream sobbing
you just feel like the care and love they
actually have for each other you know yeah
they did a really great job like I thought
we were just making fun of this movie the
whole time by myself just taking it more serious
oh [Music] looks like some Two Towers Lord
of the Rings [__] right there man
oh we believe that the battle with Darkness
will continue till all or what I lost sight
of that yes when we should have been fighting
the darkness together as a team now they're
all going to be part of the home team all
right everybody Squad up oh my God he's leading
the team the only way to stop this process
is an access code installed long ago as a
safeguard code was split along with a key
of course it was the one hiding her half of
the key it had markings in it they must complete
the access code if you will show us the way
Primal the awesome if Noah and Elena reach
the central antenna they could use the code
to shut it down and close the portal before
Unicron enters our atmosphere if we are to
die then we will die fighting all as one hell
yeah protect the key don't let them get to
the bridge
what okay it's all right they're small
[__] look at this lineup heck yeah maximals
Auto Parts
[Music]
maximize
whoa my nipples are so hard right now wow
[Music]
yes
[Music] yes that was great [Music] oh that's
an awesome Hammer nice
someone can be a real fight oh man okay there's
a fight you want you got one yes
oh [__] oh take that man
hey baby oh my God oh my God yeah miss me
holy [__] they're gonna kill off Mirage
I've had to kill him off
[Music] to die no one will remember this pathetic
planet and no one will remember you nice what
are you doing keeping my promise
oh my God what
home home team hold team [Music] oh why so
many they're all dying but I think the power
from the blast can ignite the stuff that's
in the earth in the planet and revive them
as well articulated yeah you mean this world
is already mine
person like little Pebbles like a little Bish
I'm not gonna win this one
oh Jesus he'd be sick whenever I want to give
up yeah we're always there telling me tell
him no no you have to but you're distracted
I know Hey guys you're so cute oh he's alive
I'm gonna need you to take the wheel
yes yes
exo suit
yes you can
all right now let's do this
no names over the Airways forget that [Music]
oh that made me tear up I love it so much
remember me oh [__] that was cute
whoa yes damn it's like an anime it's gonna
be a learning progress you think you can take
me on alone he's not alone he is not alone
no he's not so Rousey oh [__]
yes oh [__]
dang it
no no [Music] no
no no
wow
see the power ignites it like I was saying
yes
nice yeah get every lemon tendon yeah
laughs
no
yeah oh yes yes
that's awesome that's so awesome
be
knocked you out yay I have come here to kick
ass
you've got to be kidding me [Applause] holy
crap yes holy crap teamwork make the Dream
Work oh yeah let's end this once for all
right I got this
holy [__] nice
yes I want one
yes he is one of them now
[Music]
are we going into a Warner yeah we are wow
dope you will never see unicorn take this
world
come on girl you got this you did it broccoli
baby
no no no no no no no no no no no no no no
[Music] oh my God
this belongs to a friend of mine like it feels
like real anatomy where they're like tearing
them apart you know what I mean I will destroy
the key myself your sacrifice becomes our
oath but what it has to be another way I can
give you everything you want then die
take that Unicron
[Music]
foreign
[Music] oh
nicely done
unicorn is he dead traps but not dead sequel
we will destroy him once and for all I am
Optimus Prime leader of the Autobots good
wrap around I am Noah Diaz I gotta help save
the universe in order to save the people I
love well then that's what I'm gonna do
he's still financially struggling though
or maybe not she's gonna get a job of course
they thought about that still broke right
resumes a little thin I just recently had
a job working internationally
it was in South America it was really just
like work work work work that's a shame because
I heard the food is really good in Peru oh
[__] yeah I was like why does he seem
evil you have Terracon who are you like the
CIA or FBI or we are a secret government organization
we specialize in global threats no [__]
and we'd love to have you join the fight you
and your whole team the big guys no idea what
you're talking about are they doing what I
think they're doing I want you to know in
lieu of the things of a Grateful Nation we
will be taking care of your brother Chris's
Health Care oh my god oh I think they're building
out a universe are you serious save the world
Ken it's the least we can do
your brother's gonna be just fine the card
is gonna Chris was right by the way
no names over the airwaves this has to be
what I think it is
oh
[Music] GI Joe oh whoa oh damn they're gonna
cross them over oh my goodness my nipple chills
just got so hard right now you can literally
see them again
holy junk I was not I saw a mouth and Joe
to the camera because I was like I think that's
what they're doing but I'm not 100 sure right
now
oh
he's finally doing the mechanical issues this
is a complete waste of your skills and my
expertise I think it came out pretty good
thank you ah this car is special oh it's a
jigsaw puzzle made of garbage
The Joint don't even start yo Mirage it's
gonna show
[Music]
yeah paint job what is back this dude said
I wasn't even gonna start hahaha
oh damn what an exciting ass that's an exciting
ass ending right there
dang that movie was good that movie was so
fun I got goosebumps like four times I was
I was like enveloped in that event like it
got to a point where I'm like I my eyes are
not leaving the screen I'm So Into what's
happening right now ever I teared up like
three times I know like I was not expecting
that me neither I was like I felt I just I
was with it I felt it the way they set all
the characters up it just throughout from
the very beginning you're just like man I
really care and I always complain about like
if if there's a cool movie that has cool stuff
and they don't make us care I ate that and
this movie did a beautiful job with that I
fullheartedly agree we have to pause really
quick to talk about this GI truth yes yes
sorry because I want to talk about the movie
get in the GI but the GI Joe I mean does that
must mean they're because there was ah okay
well let me just rack my brain here there's
the GI Joe movies there's like the Channing
Tatum one and there's a sequel that starred
Dwayne Johnson which also at chanting briefly
in it and then the Transformers movies but
then bumblebee it was the prequel to this
Transformers movies and this is the sequel
to the Bumblebee and I feel like they're kind
of doing like a re-establishing resetting
of sorts so I think they're going to be rebooting
GI Joe then with him and yeah starting off
with Noah joining the the GI Joe team because
for the longest time they've been saying like
you have GI Joe you should do a Cinematic
Universe you should do a cross like a crossover
it's hasbros it's the same company so make
it happen and then yeah this is them finally
establishing that they're going to be uh doing
that which is which is a big deal that's cool
that's pretty awesome that's pretty awesome
transforming GI Joe I know imagine them right
working together the soldiers writing the
Transformers how awesome will that be oh man
I was like a huge Army of Awesomeness Holy
balls um all right I got very lucky that [__]
was not spoiled for me oh I feel like being
on the internet yeah yeah I got really lucky
yeah I mean I wouldn't I I know anyway I have
Transformers muted on my social medias because
I haven't seen it smart if I haven't seen
it like like if there's certain movies if
I'm like I might have to end up reacting this
so I'm like scream I would mute any any new
releases I end up just muting it um if you
like type in the movie and then be like yeah
on Twitter you can mute stuff yeah well well
so yeah there's ways of getting of avoiding
spoilers if you if you try hard enough avoiding
spoilers um but no I got I'm very fortunate
I'm very fortunate from you guys for not spoiling
that for me either um you did good it might
be in the review though with John and Coy
uh David's I obviously haven't watched that
video but it might be in that video uh anyway
sorry because they did a review of the movie
from out of the theater but yeah let's talk
about the movie itself good thing you didn't
watch it yeah you could think I didn't watch
it um but that that uh that's that's such
a mind-blowing uh reveal to me that's that's
such a big deal so yeah the movie itself I
I like the Transformers movies a lot of people
like the Michael Bay first one a lot I'm not
even a big fan of that one honestly I am yeah
I see a lot of people really like that one
and I'm not part of that camp uh and then
the sequels were just not my thing um I I
definitely fell asleep in the third one so
I don't even remember what happened a lot
of people like that one more than the second
one but at that point I just started really
checking out I really like bumblebee um a
lot I love Bumblebee and so good what I'll
say is like bumblebee is more like my kind
of movie Personally like my sensibilities
and the kind in terms of a Transformers movie
it might not really fit like that category
you know what I mean but that's more my kind
of movie just that like spirit and that personal
bond between Bumblebee and Haley Steinfeld
but if we're looking in the Transformers Blockbuster
action lens that box this fulfills it this
gave me finally what I've been wanting the
Transformers movies to be um where I really
like the character I like the human character
there's not a lot there's just two and instead
of the Michael Bay ones which are like a billion
human characters you don't give a [__]
about and and more importantly like it really
felt like this was about our Autobots this
felt like it was about the Transformers and
they had real distinguished not all of them
that's that's one of my little complaints
about the movie is that I felt like we could
have gone to know the maximals a little bit
better yeah we could have especially because
it's called rise of the Beast yeah so you
could have got another maximals a little bit
better uh but excuse me guys I I was really
engaged in that but I am a little bit tired
um but the um and the the uh but overall like
the Autobots the main the main core I was
like wow I'm really invested in their heart
here and I love that Optimus is it's truly
a character this time around instead of just
like a uh like the the Revere general you
know he's someone who has a character Arc
he has to go on as well here yeah that's reflective
of in our Noah character I was I was just
like wow they're doing the whole time I was
watching this I was like they're just they're
doing all the things I've wanted the Transformers
movies to do which is not I'm not really asking
for a lot face a good story you know and um
the fact that they're doing it and you could
tell what's going on in the action like when
you're in the finale one of the complaints
that a lot of us would have is I'm like this
is so messy and I can't even tell who the
bad guys are and who the good guys are but
I was like right I can tell who the good guys
are and who the bad guys are this is so well
done and I was I was I felt that wonder you
know what I mean yeah I agree it's like they
pulled the parts of Bumblebee that we all
liked where they do have a deep connection
between like human and and Transformer and
they added it into this movie with multiple
uh like Transformers and then a couple of
people and how they have to come together
to work together to like slave the world but
um I really like the outside character of
the kid like how is that going to come in
with him having sickle cell and surviving
and he's young and he is fighting through
something so extraordinary at such a young
age and of course at the end he is the one
that has to um give his brother like I like
the pep talk of his brothers now under extraordinary
circumstances which is where this 11 year
old has lived a lot of his life is extraordinary
circumstances and has fought through it and
I like that they made that connection the
human connection of like when he gives that
pep talk to his brother I was like oh God
so sad and like just great just like Bittersweet
and fantastic and those are the moments that
I always feel like movies that are super cool
they show cool stuff don't have and that heart
right there in that one moment and there were
many others in this movie luckily uh really
sold it for me like bringing him back in a
really believable way and not just like throwing
it in there of like I'm still here and still
fighting because they could have just done
that they added him into the story and it
just seemed so seamless and of course his
words were the thing to uh just to help his
brother fight and continue on and like home
team in it man yeah Propel him up yeah I mean
to your point the that's kind of like reflective
of the whole movie of what I thought bumblebee
did so well and I think the thing that they
carried over here is they maintained a heart
throughout this entire film and that's kind
of what was getting to me emotionally even
when uh air razor when air razor died was
like yeah I mean air Razor's not like the
most fleshed out character or something like
that um and there's a there's also something
too with the fact that it like it's reflective
of an animal and like an animal test so it
will get to me a lot more uh so yeah like
the fact is reflective of an animal but you
see how like uh Optimus primal was trying
to not kill her and the toll it takes and
that was the thing that stood out to me here
was wow you really get the sense that even
even for the ones you don't really get like
you don't really get to know the the maximals
that well uh for them like you need to get
to know a couple of them like primarily Primal
you don't really know them that well there's
some of the auto bets you don't really get
to know super well but regardless of that
you really get the sense of they they really
do love each other they really do care about
each other yeah and that was enough to permeate
the screen to make me feel connected to those
moments was just that driving force of them
of Love uh as they were trying they were fighting
to protect you know what I mean because that's
the the plot of like Autobots and Cybertron
and then we need to go back to Cybertron and
defend Earth and it's it's a lot of the same
beats sure um but it just hit differently
here because there was a motion there was
a motion uh layered into those scenes and
even in some of the the thing is I have a
hard time usually with these big CGI Fest
movies connecting because I'm so aware that
it's CGI and this movie managed to uh surpass
that you know what I mean like I managed to
still connect with it even when it was a big
Siege it's a CGI Fest the entire time like
yeah but yet it's I'm still like connected
to what was happening and I was I guess I
was like surprised by how connected I thought
I was just going to be like there's gonna
be cool action and then there's gonna be scenes
in between to fill the runtime and then I
was watching it like I'm actually really invested
in what's happening right now yeah and and
because they managed to just weave a good
story who's your favorite Transformer oh good
question but I was gonna say that air Razor's
like a mom and there's the moment when she
says just do it to Primal and he is holding
her and she and in that quote of saying above
all else I was like she's the mama bird who
has taught them Above All Else Like You know
what you need to do now he has taken me over
with his shitty virus excuse my language but
like and then when he when he grabs her we
see primal's pain in his face exactly and
it freaking kills me it's it's it's almost
like a you see sort of it's just like a kid
having to like kill his mom a little bit like
we see a kinship a friendship there he doesn't
want to do it but he's been taught like now
he has to and that's like oh it's that ripped
my heart out that was tough but that just
like again was just like a huge it's a huge
piece of heart that like you take that with
you and you see like how they've carried themselves
and what they've been taught and and especially
in them um protecting the humans meeting that
tribe and that tribe it was given the key
and like that's how optimists also see you
see from learning and Optimus sees them and
learns that now oh you trust humans oh we
can trust humans and that is now going to
be the only way that they all can overtake
him is now entrusting humans with them all
work together home team in it it's you make
such a great point about the motherly quality
because that's Michelle yo voices air razor
by the way oh man um and it because the motherly
moment that switch that happened for me with
her was so early on when um when she first
meets the autobots and then she turns to when
Elena's like oh I know where the thing is
it's in Peru and then when she turns to Elena
and that's Elena right now she turns to Elena
and says like are you going to be coming with
us like the way that delivery in that moment
was done I was like oh there's something so
tender about the way she's asking her yeah
in that moment I'm like I suddenly feel like
connected to you because she was also the
only one who asked her name yeah exactly yeah
yeah that was that that one that's what I
mean it's like you see these little nuances
to really elevate your movie and I'm surprises
has taken the Transformers movies like this
long this long to come I mean they had like
that one director Michael Bay first like five
of them and then who did a good job at like
a guest establishing a sense of action um
but yeah I mean and the action's good too
like the action is is great it's just I we
always talk about like if it's a horror I
want to see some cool stuff but I also want
to care about what's the people in it like
uh otherwise it's just a noise yeah yeah it's
just like oh I don't care Greg kill some more
people like nobody cares uh and they did a
great job of showing us action giving us that
really fun uh Transformers juice that we all
want yeah well also still feeding us with
characters that we really enjoy seeing and
caring about crying about and loving that's
the juice it reminded me of the physicality
because a lot of times in this Transformers
movies when you watch the action it is like
okay I'm watching things Collide and in here
when when they were like ripping each other
apart or getting hit I was like oh I actually
I feel that feel it like as if it's a human
being here you know what I mean like you said
you've when you saw it felt like it looked
like a tendons like a piece of yeah which
which is a great way to get you hooked into
the act and I think bumblebee had a similar
effect but I don't will be the one time so
I don't remember too well but here with a
bunch of with a bunch of the actions like
oh you actually feel the weight of the of
them getting hit you feel you feel the impact
it's not just big loud things hitting each
other and choreography you're like oh there's
there's actual anatomy of what's happening
right now and uh and I appreciated uh that
that context and it just looked cool too it
did look cool but it's easier to make [__]
look cool than it is for things to feel substantial
or feel like Stakes yeah I agree um I I can't
ever remember this freaking actor's name and
I feel like it's not a hard name to remember
uh let me just fight it Anthony Ramos it's
not a hard name to remember Anthony Ramos
is is a is a gem of an actor he's going to
be so so much bigger than he he's already
getting like really big but he's a prime time
nice Prime Time nice touch nice touch Dominic
Fishback or yeah Dominique Fishback I don't
know who that is that little kid was so good
did you know voice Mirage did you pick up
on The Voice did you pick up on the voice
no who was it yes take one guess he's a comedian
he's a funny man he dates nothing but really
hot famous women
come on that's gotta be the biggest clue people
are always making fun of how he dates nothing
but really hot famous woman and he's a funny
guy
well is it is it Kanye West hates him Kanye
West hates him I don't know I don't follow
a lot of is it Chris Rock no he's like probably
married oh wait is it Kevin Hart no I would
recognize Kevin Hart from anywhere is it um
see I'm not gonna be good at this game is
it who hates him what did you say hey oh my
God Kanye West hates everybody um commit I
don't oh wait he was Mexican right it was
he I don't know this is not gonna be a game
I'm gonna win who was it Pete Davidson oh
really yeah oh my God yes of course when you
said he hates him oh my God I'm so not I'm
not up on the juice I knew like two months
of him and Kardash like dating I was like
I don't read I don't read the the Vogue uh
headlines in who's dating who anyway okay
yes now I'm with it yeah I'm with it now yeah
I liked him I could see how that's a character
people might not be able to get on board with
because there's a couple of points if you're
like turn down the jokes a little bit Yeah
but more often than not I was like um I find
this charming and it's it's a different take
on the whole because normally it's like make
Bumblebee the one who's connected to the human
you know that's normally what they do and
this was a different kind of this is a different
kind of take and sometimes was a little too
jokey sure but more often than not I know
Transformers like became famous from like
being an 80s cartoon and there was a lot about
the personalities like sort of reminded me
of that yeah like art some of the voice works
on like RC the the girl who's like acrobatic
and the yeah the bike the Ducati yeah yeah
yeah and then uh and then Pete Davidson too
who just reminded me of like an 80s reminder
of like 80s characters to me so I I is like
an 80s character yeah so I thought it was
funny I thought it was funny and Charming
I did too um good music all around everything
was good uh yeah my only complaint really
is that uh I just kind of wish I got to know
some of those the maximum they call it rise
of the Beast and I kind of wish I gotta know
them a little more maybe in the next one we
will that's my main my main little thing and
better than that no man it's such an improvement
over what that came before that I'm like I
got I got no complaints the fact that it's
such an improvement uh like Nine Stars Nine
Stars Nine Stars baby that's where we're at
ladies and gentlemen what are your nitpicks
leave them down below uh make sure to follow
Tara thank you to all who followed us on our
patreon page and um yeah uh I think we should
the patron of the day shout out Maria Hammond
now Maria I give sincere shout outs to Maria
okay all right because we were talking in
a review about how uh air razor had such a
motherly tender quality and I am often saying
about Maria that in a lot of ways you know
yes mother in real life but specifically uh
to us and and to me as well she's constantly
with more than just actual physical gifts
and she gives us quite a lot of gifts and
even Olivia she sends Olivia quite a lot of
gifts too that's so sweet but also just like
the words of wisdom and uh the the just the
overall tender messages that she constantly
sends us so it's just an overwhelming amount
of love and support like when I say overwhelming
it's overwhelming like there's no one else
really out there like you to treats us this
way can I get a message Maria yes
Tara needs some love man turning some love
Maria so I just want to say I love you and
thank you for the love that you're constantly
flowing our way that energy is always well
received and and it's something that we definitely
need we feed off your love Maria so thank
you for being you and yeah what the I need
to adjust that she got us that cool thing
back there that I need to adjust so thank
you for being you and uh looking forward to
another lovely message from you soon and I'm
looking forward to mine bye take character
foreign